hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to neverending
nightmares if this is a very short
episode which in the future I will know
but right now I do not know because I am
in the past currently but to you I'm in
the future anyway this might be stitched
on the end last one or am I being a
selling Sabourin episode here I don't
know I'm a little kid this turned into
among the sleep and I don't know why I
would like to know why I would like to
know I the toy soldiers on the toilet I
would like to know why my teddy bear is
on the floor I'd like to know a lot of
things Oh at least I still have the
creepiest dolls I'm a guessing I just
regress back to childhood for some
repressed memory here looks like that
one in the bottom left corner was
actually moving so I'm glad it's not oh
good a big ticking clock are they gonna
cuckoo and cut somebody's head off Conan
O'Brien Conan you hear Conan the
Barbarian all that just led back to
where I was I was going the wrong way
hey this kid's got more stamina than
adult meat I'm just assuming that the
same person
all right oh good it is the same perfect
and blood wonderful very good very good
what am i doing what in the world is
going on what am i doing why am i
leaving why am i walking in the darkness
also why my a child babies
[Music]
okay yeah I saw that right it's kind of
gone now that was a thing standing there
there was so a thing standing there oh
what the hell is going on in this
goddamn game okay its leading up to
something how much care for it's very
loud in my ears why
why
why oh this is the same old same old
right hello Napoleon I'll be on my way
now he's happening it's weirder the fact
that nothing's happening is kinda the
same it's lead me to believe that
something big is gonna happen down in
the future
like that really big baby is gonna get
combined with the blind douche oh okay
at least the books are on fire again
[Music]
looks like a much older version of my
brother oh good it is my brother
my brother Thomas has got to go together
okay
wait what's left now what is what is
left
hello little girl how are you doing did
I just oh oh wait that that might be
normal this might be normal this eyes
might still be normal
yeah yeah might still be no more that
was there before so Who am I to say it's
not normal now
[Music]
okay
was going on I would really like to know
where am I going
am I going the right way
hello
[Music]
I have no idea I have no idea I got
nothing to move there's that pain again
huh that's still very angry oh that's
the kid that was me that I must be me as
a kid okay I don't know why I didn't get
that right off the bat or I wasn't
certain about I knew it but I wouldn't
third certain so I'm going back wait I'm
going backwards in the game I'm going
back to the bed that I first came from
right that's not right wait wait did I
get turned around here what wait a
minute hey some sounds not quite right
here this would be the first room I came
out I'd be the closet this so is among
the sleep oh my god
it's among the sleep in the future it's
when the kid grows up he's all screwed
up in the head cuz he went to nightmare
land am I not supposed to be here oh
come on what I'm supposed to be here am
I going to Narnia did I just go really
really really the wrong way
I went really the wrong way well hey I
go all the N I'm gonna be back in a
little bit
don't don't tire yourself out kid
oh there's no that's not Conan O'Brien
that's uh dr. Wilson from house why is
he here why is that important
sorry all you generals I'm just wheezing
in front of you and guy being stoned
whoa whoa whoa whoa save me Wilson No
kind of weird are you I just got eaten
by the darkness their combination the
amnesia among this sleep outlast it's
got everything except for colors I
really gotta say though I love the way
this this style just works it works oh
hey I got asthma so just bear with me a
little bit here can't hear me wheezing
get back here Gabby I don't know if
you're my doctor and my sister but your
wound I get in here whatever come on
wait which way did you hello mr. hooter
al Wow what big eyes you have
huh the better to eat my soul with
oh I picked their whole eyes eyes up
Thomas what my name is not Thomas you
had a painting of my brother Thomas is
my brother's name not my name more eyes
I see those dead thing Oh Oh Oh God aah
triple foe be tripped up trip Tobin
phobia is there like a specific way I'm
supposed to go I don't know if I'm
supposed to go
i I am Gabby if you would stick a little
closer to me guide me I got I'm dragging
this rabbit's very heavy solid gold very
valuable oh is that another thing do I
want to look at that one too oh good I
can't look at that one I mean oh no I
can't look at the horribly disfigured
rotten thing I am God you try running
with a solid gold bunny and I'm at full
speed
oh there's another one I really don't
think it matters which direction I go oh
come on just look at the squirrel Oh
as king of the squirrels I'm not too
happy about that
did I go the wrong way don't tell me I'm
just gonna be cycling through these
woods over and over again waiting to
pick the exact correct way to go because
I will run out of patience oh oh
Bambino oh good I didn't want to look at
that I can't look at that one closely oh
oh it's from the beginning of the game
oh good I have asthma I'm actually an
adult name airing myself into a kid's
body I don't know Honor if these names
are if these names are Kickstarter
supporters where'd you go do you go I'm
gonna go north because I haven't gotten
north yet these are these we've got to
be a Kickstarter supporter so kudos to
all of you what is that
dammit I went the wrong way I should've
thought I saw something one of the
Great's of look like it was the big baby
again
how many times am I gonna run out of
breath here yeah yeah I get it all
together get it all together there we go
I'm trying it's harder than you think
not really but I'm very wimpy I was
always picked last in sports
I am Oh Bambino Bambi No
where am I what could possibly be in
these woods and I need to see so badly
that it call come Oh
oh hello mr. owl could see you again oh
yeah this crow friends and bird and
woodland creatures did you kill Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]
why well I'm gonna don't who is that
sorry but you're in the face
[Music]
stay down that's right
yeah you better stay down this game's
longer than I thought it was everybody
in that bed know I'm out
ye
[Music]
well I'm back in the asain asylum again
this just seems to be less blood let's
crotch stabby holes kathas gonna take
forever to go through hi oh you're just
resting Archie you're not actually
sitting up God good wouldn't want to
bother you and on my time of need
wonder what monstrosity awaits me in
this part of the game hello oh good a
pitch black hole in the ground do I jump
in oh I literally jumped in ok then I'm
confused oh no where'd my neighbor go
did he get up he got up oh hi I don't
know what I'm gonna see in here hello
again excuse me while I just disappear
for a little bit I'm a new man hi I got
6th fret up
I don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it I don't like this hmm
Tom's gonna happen I know something
gonna happen cuz I know something's
gonna happen all the force was a big
lead up something's gonna happen what is
that oh [ __ ] you holy [ __ ] you know that
was like the creepiest thing I've ever
seen in my goddamn life
you screw yourself you goddamned
Cheshire Cat smile and you somebody was
building up to something I knew it was
you can't fool me about this goddamn
game I know your tricks I know how you
play I think you can get a get the drop
on me
no no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
sure you left I hear you left bye are
you nuts you know don't run out of
breath please for the love of God run
well I thought I was free and clear
through the doorway turns out I was not
can i I just I didn't want to run out of
breath so that's why I kind of paused
but that was dumb apparently that was
doubt that was dumb so I'm gonna save up
oh god he's here I didn't know no he's
here oh oh I'm dead I need to start
running butts quicker okay I'm just
gonna I'm gonna go for it much sooner
than that
I'm all rested up here we go here we go
okay Ryan about at the animal testicles
here we go here we go ah do not if you
run out of breath I swear I will kill
you okay we're fine we're fine we are
fine we are good we're good
well hello mr. and mrs. whatever the
hell your name is
maybe those are family portraits of
Kickstarter people I don't know could
that be what that is I have no idea oh
boy oh it's a nice a medieval operating
theater this is where dr. Frankenstein
went insane
they created the creepy ass version of
me I'm just making a loop I'm going
backwards and forwards forwards and
backwards all over the place up-down
left-right a ba ba
Oh God my throat it's not doing too well
I did just recover from a sickness so
hello
someone in here someone being examined
quite sadly oh good the autopsy room no
no no no on the world am i locking these
things that's what I want to know now oh
I already went in there sorry I'm dumb
I'm dumb I went in there so I guess I
need to go all the way to the left I
don't remember where I came from so I
hope I don't go backwards but I think I
need to go laughter yeah okay yeah I
know you can't run for crowd I'll go to
another hole in the ground perfect yay
hooray okay anyway I think I am played
out for this episode and it's getting a
bit darker I don't have my lights set up
so it's getting a little more for these
Let's Plays of poor or so in the next
episodes this is a lot longer than I
thought it'd be people said that it was
only an hour long but apparently there's
more to it than that but either way
thank you all so much for watching I'm
getting very close to the end here I
hope it's not like a minute long or
something but thank you again everybody
for watching and check out my other
Let's Plays in the description below or
in the annotations and as always I will
see you in the next video
job I could have gotten more money
watching
[Music]